is a journalist with sport Italia and he
witnessed that post-match altercation
and joins us now from Milan Jan Luca
really good to have you with us so
you're able to see what Jose was saying
to Anthony Taylor just take us into that
space what was going on and how did the
two men uh come across each other
good morning good morning guys well our
first was a very quiet situation in the
Indian side part of the pushka sorry and
I would like to start from them because
the the game was a tough game was a
rough game and a lot of controversy also
in the press conference with the Jose
Mourinho Jose Mourinho
um with us in the in the mid Zone area
and then goes to the buzz Zone and you
see in the video the bazon and Mourinho
way for the group of the referees after
the Jose mourinopas in their Zone the
referee group with Roberto Rosetti which
is the which is which is the weather
referee's committee chairman pass in the
zone you see in the video that Rosetti
amorino arguing each other they knew
each other Roberto city was the ref in
Italy in charge in 2008 2010 the years
which Jose Mourinho was in the on the
bench or FC inter many maybe they smile
and then the show of Jose Mourinho with
the bad words with the words in Italian
in Italian he said also Roberto Rosetti
agree with me that was not a penalty
what a penalty we are talking about the
penalty tailor give to Sevilla and the
second half from the contact between who
Campos the penalty was canceled by uh
continues to talk about the reference in
the press conference talks but I think
that this is was not an English
references Spain reference and he
continues this acting and I would like
to to tell you something look he stares
a lot of time to us so I think Alpha it
was very
um very intense to talk with Taylor but
I think enough is the Jose Mourinho
acting is what all his features his
classic features trademark to have this
communication impact on the situation
and this was uh the main characteristic
of Jose Mourinho we now we are not
talking about the game the match the
plane of Isa Roma against evilia but
from this part of the of the game he
threw his medal to a fan this is Jose
Mourinho look how he stares to us we
were a group of reporter of Italian
reporter and then Mourinho starts to act
and then
certain Interruption I just want to get
another question to you because
obviously this happens well after the
game Wednesday night then Anthony tell
is traveling back yesterday how
how was Jose's Behavior received by Roma
fans because of course the the
suggestion is that these Aroma fans on
their way back who perhaps had seen Jose
Mourinho shouting Anthony Taylor and
thought they'd have a go as well what
was the sort of reaction in Italian
media after seeing Jose's Behavior
uh the Italian median are all astonished
about this image this chain that flew in
the head of the of the tailor and his
families these are very bad bad image um
I think there is strong word to say that
the Roman people lead the uh are lead by
Jose Mourinho in these uh in this in
this Behavior they were angry also
without knowing what the Gisele Mourinho
did in the internal part of the push
Casino we have a chat with all the
supporters and we're very very uh very
angry but this uh is a small machine
like uh behavior from and I can I can
tell you something yesterday all these
start at uh 7 30 in the in the evening
between Terminal A and terminal uh B
Taylor was adding a little break at the
bar table with this family and then a
small group of uh as a rumors supporters
recognized him and firstly
um he they start to insult him with
chance and so on and then the situation
uh the situation turned very bad
suddenly you you saw the chair and what
can I say the one is Roma supporters was
arrested and now he's still in Budapest
so this is the situation this is the
best situation after after the game but
there are a lot of controversy from the
Jose Mourinho Behavior also in the pitch
and outside the pitch and also the ice
Aroma Behavior player behavior in the
pitch and that's how the pitch that's
the situation a bad situation from
Italian football really appreciate your
analysis generally because this is
definitely a story that's going to have
implications uh not least the safety of
referees after the game right John Luca
bisco glucosi thank you very much
thank you thank you so much have a nice
day